would you say that like a lot of the
females are like
emotion guided
so like to to different like situations
and stuff
it just depends on the situation
yeah it just depends on the situation
because if it's a situation where it's
now affecting me mentally then we have a
problem
whereas like if i'm if i'm okay with it
and i can deal with it then i'm all
right type thing because normally um
because normally the like it's been i
don't know where it's been said but like
like when it's like hard decisions not
necessarily like buying a house but like
men tend to be more saints and like in
and like more composed
whereas like women are like more like
but if the emotion is maybe we
as well
like not just the decision like what
else could affect the decision like what
more is there to it like you could buy a
house but i'm thinking like is the train
station there like can i get to college
can i go to work
there's just so much more to the
decision
i feel like
right yeah that's a bit generalizing
though i feel like yeah like
any man could think like that as well
any
woman yeah hear what you're saying
we all
we are we naturally or at least we
develop
responding with emotion and then there
are those of us who develop trying to
suppress that and responding with logic
but majority of time we all respond at
least i would say we respond with
emotion first
in
most situations we think everyone like
male to females yeah 100 oh i don't
women are chemically different every
single day
like depending on where we're at in our
cycle like before or before that's like
why we get super irritable before our
period
so i think men like naturally or more
he's had enough
like you don't understand
second day that
first day is like the come on it's cool
the second day the second day oh my god
have you been around jesus christ
like i just think that like women come
more from a place like and i'm a pretty
logical girl but like yeah i feel like
even i feel like the most logical girls
we acknowledge that we're emotional like
emotional beings and we kind of look to
men to be more logical
you know you've never noticed a
difference in the emotions between men
and women during the time of the month
women have like more mood swings
just in general like women because you
said you think it's equal and i'm just
shocked because no i meant i feel like
we equally in situations
equally
would naturally respond emotionally not
all the time but i feel like it's i feel
like i think you're an emotional male
oh yeah
yeah definitely
as in being in touch with my emotions
yeah yeah yeah 100 yeah i'm not
stone cold
sometimes it's so especially like
relationships it's so hard to
communicate with you guys and come to an
agreement because
y'all don't want to be vulnerable i'm
not talking like oh we're talking
generally
so it makes it harder
like we'll we'll have a whole
we'll talk for like 30 minutes and
you'll be like cool why
and i'm sat here explaining to you why
yeah i don't know
i know you're thinking more than you're
saying you have to put it on the table
nah but you know what it is you gotta
you gotta understand right when you're
in a relationship with like uh together
right and let's say you you have a
disagreement about it right a man will
only go to like a certain level we will
go and we'll tell you the logic side of
it will tell you the facts and stuff
like that your emotions take over to a
point where
we just want to leave we just don't want
to continue with the conversation
because like we're not no man has ever
won an argument with a woman like
if he's one no but like you know but you
know i mean that you know i mean that
you know what i mean it's like no matter
no matter if you think you won you
haven't won you know what i'm trying to
say like i guess like for example the
way i feel if like if i've had an
argument ago it's like
i'll be done it's not about winning the
argument it's about coming to an
agreement either you agree to disagree
or come to an agreement if you're wrong
if you're wrong
but the thing is
in a healthy relationship we don't argue
to win
but but the thing is like
you say you want emotional availability
but women aren't attracted to that i was
done i was going to say i was going to
say that i was going to say that
because
when when a guy when a guy
when a guy shows a vulnerability yeah
girls think oh they want a guy who like
cares but when it when they show a bit
of like sensitivity and stuff then they
get turned off like they're like they
don't like that but who said that then
you've been like
they've studied this like when men
when men cry there's been multiple
studies that say when
when men cry when men cry in front of
women the woman loses respect for him
and it's not and and i would be in you
know what here's have you ever dated an
[ __ ]
go that's what i mean
wait so you dated an [ __ ] right so
you're attracted you're not attracted to
emotional availability that's what i
wanted i wanted someone to be no but no
you didn't because that's who you were
sleeping with
that's what you think you want but it's
not what you actually want go ahead yeah
like go gosh yeah
they like they like bad boys like when
the guys they say oh they want a nice
guy does all of this like and then when
that guy comes around they're like oh
whatever then they're like well
personally what's that
it's literally it's literally you know
what it is it's literally it's literally
the
nice guy's finished lost theory yeah
because you know what it is yeah girls
will say
the girls will say listen i want a guy
that's like let's say the provider that
can take care of me that's nice caring
compassionate emote like emotionally
available and stuff yeah but when that
guy comes around like you said yeah it's
like they look they took one look at him
they gave him like
one two maybe three dates if you're
lucky yeah but if you show that that
you're there for her like emotion and
stuff like that that's not attractive to
the woman the woman the woman and i've
said it's an older podcast
me i'm a very emotional person like i
feel like if you can now connect to me
on that level then i'm good because
clear communication and expressing
yourself to me
allows me to express me to you type
thing i don't feel like
not like at the start when your first
like day and that's like deep like when
you're in when you've known each other
for a couple years maybe
not a couple years exactly like this i
can have an emotional like connection
with someone in a week yeah i feel like
i need to have that conversation with
you can you open up exactly because are
you able to open up because a lot of men
they get taught from their mothers and
family to not be emotional to not talk
about their emotions to be a man to be
strong you know all of that so that's
why i feel like a lot of men also have
problems communicating their feelings
because they're not used to it
how long do you guys think that you
should be seeing a girl before you like
start to open up emotionally i think i
should do it as little as possible to be
honest because because it's bad advice
like you know i'm telling you like i
think you guys come at it with like a
good a good heart
but like
you're chemically less attracted to men
that are vulnerable
because like and it's not it's not a
nice reality but this is this is how i
know it every time i ask girls have you
dated an [ __ ] they always say yes
they always say yes back that a second
because you said like why would you keep
on sleeping with that person i think for
a couple weeks you still have that hope
that he might open up someday but you
end up leaving you do but that's the
reason you're not in a relationship with
that [ __ ] you're just dating him well
did he want to be in a relationship the
[ __ ]
probably not no comment yeah that's
that's what i'm saying but it's always
really good
and this is this is what i'm saying like
like in the reason the reason there's
like biological reasons that we feel the
way we feel and we can't just undo them
so the reason is because the same traits
that make the guy the hero also make him
the villain
so like like the guy that's the
protector provider like he he he has to
be you know aggressive on some level he
has to be able able to protect you and
emotionally in control you don't see
superman crying like
like in a movie you see hulk when he
like just goes all the way back to human
just for his girl
not necessarily crying him crying yeah
was he was better when he was green
hulk hulk found his hulk found his piece
muscles
so what would you say um
about i was just fictional about
leonidas to his queen in 300.
you know for
before his next action before kicking
the messenger down the pit i mean i
think you can always find exceptions to
the rule but that doesn't make it the
rule fair enough like just because you
can name one example doesn't it
like
and it's just like i just think we
confuse men and it makes them more like
feminine
and it's we're not attracted to it it's
not fun like i don't enjoy being
attracted to [ __ ] but i i like
i don't i don't enjoy it but like you
can't admit you can't deny that it's
there you know what i mean got it
for me like being emotionally available
as a guy means also like
or specifically means you can
communicate with me it's not just about
like crying or you know breaking down or
anything like that it's just can you
tell me how you're feeling and i'm not
talking about like oh i'm so sad i mean
like
openly communicate with me what's going
right what's going wrong like just talk
to me yeah because a lot of guys when
you ask them like what's going on
they're like i'm good i'm good yes
what does what does i'm good means it's
exactly the same it's exactly the same
as i'm fine when you're not fine oh but
guys do that too yeah no that's what i
don't know that's what i'm saying i'm
good it's exactly the same as when you
go say i'm fine when you don't when
you're not actually fine that's
basically what it is but we we as guys
just don't like the better we say we're
fine yeah and then we come back and
we're like okay this is what's actually
going on you guys never come back we'll
ask you 10 times like what's going on
and then you'll feel like we're
pestering you exactly
you kind of have to drag them yeah
but that's that's why but but that's why
like like she said that like yo you're
like not more attracted to the arseholes
in it because like if we start opening
up like maybe not to you or whatever
like you're maybe like one in a million
but like
if we start opening up to you like after
we say like oh i'm good and i come back
and i tell you what's actually happening
you'll lose respect for me you'll lose
that's it
i've been in a relationship where a guy
told me everything that was bothering
him and i was going nuts
like i don't i don't want to hear every
single problem you have like you you're
not you're their therapist
like
and and this is but we have to be yours
as guys we have to stop no no no that's
a double that's the double because
listen you don't want to be our
therapist no no no you don't want to be
you don't want to be our therapist but
we we
have been no you don't want to be our
therapist yeah but
we as guys have been but like not even
qualified to do but we're your therapist
because when when you talk we listen we
listen good to every little thing sally
what's really rude to me today
but i'm not gonna lie i feel like women
we don't tell
the guys everything either
like we don't tell them everything so i
feel like there has to be a balance like
i want to know about your life i want to
know what's going on and you do the same
but like there's the communication part
of it
just be open but you know don't tell me
everything
but do you see how confusing that is for
guys because you're like tell me
something but don't tell me everything
like
where is the line where is your line
like where's your guys's line
just tell me like tell me about the day
cool i woke up went to work come back is
that like is that the line is that
roughly where the line is like because
that's what it feels like it's like say
something happened and it made you feel
some type of way that's what i want to
know because that's what is has stuck
with you throughout the day
oh i woke up i brushed my teeth i knew
that no but a lot of guys a lot of guys
growing up not being not knowing how to
communicate with their emotions so when
they're in when they're adults in their
relationships they don't even know where
to start so if somebody else i'm
literally that guy how's your day
there's okay
like
you know i mean i'm cool how are you i'm
cool just because i won't even know
where to start if i'm to express
whatever it is i'm going through do you
know what i'm trying to say i feel like
from their own experience as well
when they have
like opened up or
like told them about the whole day or
whatever yeah it hasn't worked for them
yeah what's worked for them is like yeah
nothing i'm cool i'm good like that's
worked for them so yeah
yeah but wouldn't you want like a person
that you're able to actually talk to how
you feel yeah family members
other guys but like in a woman
no we don't we don't
well i just think like when you're when
you're asking guys to do that you're
asking them to be more feminine
inerrantly and like in the long run
you're not going to be attracted to that
i think i think you guys can relate to
that but if a guy if i love someone or i
care about someone what's bothering them
is bothering me
so if they're in a bad mood it's going
to affect me either way so i want to
know what it is so we can figure it out
and that's when
i'm sorry it's [ __ ] up because men
don't open up and then we're just
sitting there like
in a bad mood bad energy bad vibes
well i need you to be vulnerable i need
to tell me what's going on because it's
affecting me now as well and us
as a team
yeah but like you know what yeah i found
something else to flip it on you like
you know when you're you know when
you're the one that's upset but then
they
flip on you like why she gets upset with
you for being upset with yeah like
like what
how does that work
like like dude they would be like two
guys baby what's wrong nah i'm good in
it cool so they walk away they don't
fight they don't come back yes they come
back why are you always upset like they
come here
i swear like hold on that's the thing
because if we ask you what's going on
and you're like i'm fine i'm good
whatever that's why we get annoyed yeah
exactly
but i'm the one that's upset why are you
flipping but i think the real problem is
initially the guy's not in control of
his emotions
like i don't think it's the i think if
he was just in control of his emotions
to start and if he like and if he can
give you one specific thing to like like
work on that's one thing but it's when
the guys being all emotional and like
having a hissy fit and you're like what
the
is there an issue
but um i'm gonna read guys there's two
super chats but one isn't loading i'm
sorry also all super chats are going
towards a second camera um i'd really
like to get it
um next month so you get paid on youtube
monthly so all the super chats you guys
send this month i'm gonna get next month
so hopefully i need to raise like 200
more dollars
um help her out guys yeah she's doing
great she's doing great
okay so um one super chat was let me
find it um okay ask how many times per
week can a man cry
my negative one
after the ladies how many how many times
a week can your
i think man
depends like say first exactly imagine
he's lost someone important to him like
cry as much as you want you have to get
it out
but if it's like like you said like just
give us a block just give us a blunt
honest number
what's more attractive a man that can
like hold it together and be strong or a
man that's like blubbering on the floor
like crying for like weeks being
vulnerable and crying
but but you date the [ __ ] oh
no listen like i said it depends the
situation if it comes home and he's like
so you annoyed me at work and started
like
oh that's an ick yeah okay okay so if
you lose something he loses someone
close to him he's crying every day yeah
for two three weeks straight every
single day you're you're you're just
fine but you're doing the same thing for
two years yeah but you're a girl so like
but you're equally you're equally
attracted but she's i'm sorry
you want to screw him the same no but i
mean there's a way to deal with that
because if i i'm there for you so i'm
gonna help you get up yes a long time
yeah i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to
step in now because i've allowed you one
two weeks all right but no no we need to
work on this let's let's
even if i if if i was a girl i even i'd
be like listen bro like you need to fix
up like that
you had your time to move like you had
your time to like you know cry and yeah
still going you know what i mean
we're going to learn how to deal with
this because there's no way i'm going to
watch someone cry
no like every person obviously every
person here has like
different ways of dealing with it like
whether that's crying for weeks on end
or kind of like getting back to work
everyone's but like
there's a certain time where it's like
yo like like you're living like
the person's gonna be loved and
remembered you're gonna go
put flowers in the grave and light a
candle and you know just chill there and
talk to that grave you know what i mean
but like life goes on like you gotta
like move past that no matter obviously
it's gonna be hard but yeah deal with it
like the way you wanna do it i don't
think there's i don't think there's a
time limit on that like for example my
friend
lost his mom um he lost his dad when he
was much younger when he was a child and
then he lost his mom and he's his only
only child like if he wanted to cry for
a whole year i get it because that was
the only person you were close to like
he has family like uncles and aunties
and stuff yeah but like we get it yeah
well i mean
i think girls get it i think girls get
it but we're just not attracted to it
yeah i was gonna say your question was
are you are you more attracted to
someone who's gonna deal with it
straight away start going gym like deal
with it that way or
it's gonna
okay like cry a little bit
but then you're not gonna be attracted
to someone that's you're gonna be more
attracted to someone who's like wow
they're going out there they're doing
like i don't know like charity marathons
for whatever or they're like they're
doing something active you know to like
get over it making sure that's still
gonna like she said okay
and how you're dealing with it she's
like i get that but she's saying what's
more attractive
i think it depends on if
crying every day every day for however
however long is fine
if you're not moping about if you're
still proactive so if he's still
proactive he's still doing what he needs
to do but every now and again
you know he'll catch himself thinking
about the person he lost and he cries
that's perfectly fine but if he's just
doing nothing and dedicating his you
know every waking hour to just crying
and not yeah being motivated and i can
completely understand that you know that
being a turn off but i feel like i'm not
a woman but i feel like a woman can
still find a guy attractive if he's
crying every day but still showing her
masculine yeah
i just
i think
and this is bad this is bad but it's
just honest like i think a woman can
understand yeah but i don't think a girl
really is going to want to screw you
after she's seen you crying i just don't
think we're turning
bring them bring them down a bit as well
if they're trying to always cheer you up
yeah it's going to bring you down as
well a little bit yeah and like it's not
it's not fun i don't enjoy this it's
just i just think it's how we're wired
like we want we want the guy like the
the men i respect the most in my life
like when i think of them they don't cry
yeah like my dad i've seen him cry like
twice there's no one i respect more than
my dad
and every time like i've seen him yeah
twice in my life
and it's much better to like i think
have like strong masculine presence and
then occasionally like when you when if
that happens now and then it's like
rather than someone that's blubbering
like or every every time something goes
wrong they're blubbering because how am
i supposed to trust you if you're like
in your feminine and like every time
something goes wrong
i guess it depends it depends on the
frequency yeah yeah if
if it's all the time it's a bit
i feel like for that sort of reason as
well that's why like a lot of men they
go there's a lot more men that um commit
suicide than females yeah i think
it's it's got a lot to do with that as
well because they don't want to see be
seen vulnerable by their partner or they
don't want to
show emotions so
they let it build up by trying to be
active or do whatever rather than just
let out yeah it builds up mentally and
then they end up like killing themself
or you know being depressed or like
gets worse
so i feel like when women can
let her out they can cry whether they
could talk talk or whatever about their
problems
and i feel like it can get dealt with
better
because um
they're allowed to they're allowed to by
society basically so
yeah well i think i think men should be
able to like cry and be emotional i just
think they should be able to they should
do it to other men
that's the worst nah that that's that's
even wrong
you can't you can call it the worst but
it's honest like i'm just being honest
like your girl is not going to respect
you like every study that's ever studied
this
ever
has has come to the conclusion that if
the girl
if if the guy cries in front of the girl
she does not respect you the same and so
like i could lie to like i could lie to
you and say oh and like pretend i'm
different
and but i'm like being honest like i i
don't think it's wise to cry in front of
your girl all the time like she's not i
mean
even
yeah like i don't know like how often
you guys cry oh yeah let me know carl
actually i've not cried in a minute
i've not cried in a minute there's
nothing there no no i actually learned
like the last time i've cried i remember
specifically that was when my great
grandma passed away but the way i cried
was like it was one of those things
where i walked in here and i saw her
like in the casket stuff like that and
then i just stared for a minute and then
i didn't like
cry but it was automatic like my tears
just started pouring out so i'm just
there with the most straightest face and
like
yeah it's like it's like you know when
you're trying to hold like you'd be
trying to be gangster be like
but it's just
automatic
you know
yeah
and that was like
six years ago
i'm going to read the super chats really
quick okay
my favorite donut sentience
50 come on girl
come on my
he's
god
okay um again guys